rejected titles mirror troubles and
martial arts Legends of the past and
future turns out you don't need a huge
budget to make a masterpiece like Enter
the Dragon
Bruce Lee didn't necessarily come to
America to be a movie star in fact
according to Lee himself he came to
America to escape his growing Life as a
street criminal in America he began
teaching Wing Chun Kung Fu and gained
reputation as one of the best martial
arts instructors in the country giving
him a star-studied cast of students
Lee's student list would be the Envy of
any Star Struck Sensei according to
asianjournalusa.com he taught Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar Lee Marvin Roman Polansky
and Sharon Tate he also trained martial
arts Legends Chuck Norris and takikamara
but according to several sources James
Coburn was Lee's favorite Hollywood
student Coburn was a pallbearer at Lee's
Funeral as was Coburn's fellow The
Magnificent Seven Alum Stephen Queen
given McQueen's lifelong reputation as
one of Hollywood's true tough guys his
friendship with Lee spoke to his deep
respect for the man not as a fighter
Steve Steve McQueen's that son of a gun
got the toughness in him while he
reportedly fell out with some of his
A-list clients at the time because of
his own Hollywood Ambitions no doubt he
learned some kernels of Showbiz wisdom
while teaching them how to throw kicks
and punches like a true master
if you're a fan of kung fu films you
probably watch the Ip Man series Ip Man
was a real Wing Chun master and his
skill was so legendary that he had a
film series based on him an honor
attained by almost no other living
Sensei it makes sense then that it man
was Lee's Kung poo master that also
explains Lee's Devotion to authenticity
Not only was he a legitimate martial
artist but the best way to honor his
master in the man's teachings would be
to authentically share them with a world
audience Ip Man was such a legendary and
skilled martial artist that not only did
he Inspire the four Ip Man films in the
main series and several other Standalone
Ip Man films but he's also the focus of
a film called the Grand Master the actor
who played Ip Man in the popular series
Donna Yen would achieve American
mainstream success for his role as a
force monk in Rogue One Star Wars story
there's no doubt having trained under a
real master whose life also makes such
compelling Cinema would go on to
influence Bruce Lee's films including
Enter the Dragon
although Warner Brothers Pictures got
behind Enter the Dragon and bet on Bruce
Lee becoming a star he still had trouble
convincing the executives there of his
vision Lee's daughter Shannon wrote in
her book the water my friend the
teachings of Bruce Lee that her father
battled the studio over the Enter the
Dragon screenplay as Shannon put it the
original script had none of the iconic
scenes that exist today
oh don't get back
Warner Brothers reportedly brought in a
screenwriter who didn't know much about
Kung Fu Lee protested and according to
Shannon the star himself rewrote most of
the screenplay although Warner Brothers
promised to get rid of the writer of the
studio secretly sent him to Hong Kong
instead to continue working on the
script while not incorporating any of
these changes as a result Lee did not
show up to begin filming for two weeks
stand off with the studio that he
eventually won his changes were utilized
in the screenplay and Lee made Enter the
Dragon well and truly his own
Bruce Lee's issues with the filament
script also included his dislike for the
alternate titles that the studio wanted
to use including Blood and Steel and
Hans Island the big problem seemed to be
that the studio wanted a blood-filled
fighting movie while Lee wanted
something more Transcendent Steve than
the philosophical Pursuits that had
defined Lee's martial arts Pursuits
Blood and Steel hinted at a lurid action
movie which could be considered a draw
for an audience whose knowledge of kung
fu was limited at the time it might have
also been a reference to the steel blade
hand that the villainous Han busts out
in his fight against Lee Hans Island was
a pretty on the nose title that simply
explained the setting of the movie a
tournament on opium Kingpin Hans private
[__] Enter the Dragon gave the movie
the depth that Lee brought to his
martial arts and the dragon and the
title hinted at the Heritage that was so
important to Lee
for Lee bringing legitimacy to his first
big Hollywood film was everything he
wanted it to be as genuine as possible
from the locations to the philosophies
he studied even more important to him
was the authenticity of the martial arts
practice in the movie a good fight
should be
like a small play but
played seriously John Saxon who played
Roper trained in Judo and karate for
years before Enter the Dragon Jim Kelly
who handled the role of Williams was a
black belt and international karate
champion he and she who played Han had
been training in martial arts for most
of his life and starred in several
hundred martial arts films Bob Wall
Angela Mao bolo young and Samo hung were
a few of the other big names in martial
arts surround out the cast
according to variety racial issues also
affected Lee's big Studio film with
Warner Brothers Leah long dealt with
racism and intolerance in America but
Shannon Lee explained in her book how
Warner Brothers was influenced by the
racial sentiments at the time writing
Hollywood build it as a double lead in
case their gamble on my father didn't
pay off and in part due to the intense
Prejudice and concern surrounding the
xenophobia of audiences of that time in
the film's opening credits it's John
Saxon who shares co-lead credit with Lee
but both he and Jim Kelly Share coverage
on the movie poster Kelly was an
American and a great martial artist but
he was black while Saxon was American
and white either way according to
Shannon Lee the studio didn't think an
Asian man would be able to carry the
film regardless of the fact that he was
arguably the best martial artist of his
generation thankfully Lee's role is a
champion of Eastern culture continues
today and the endless influence his
philosophy and his films continue to
have
one of the most eye-catching scenes in
Enter the Dragon is the one where Han
lures Lee into a Hall of Mirrors the
disorienting nature of that scene isn't
just a camera trick it was actually a
tough scene to execute they had to build
a closet full of mirrors then shoot
inside it despite any and all challenges
of reflection lighting and movement
cinematographer Phil hubs went through
the process in a q a about the film
according to Hubs the sequence was
director Robert klaus's idea when they
shot it they would cut a hole in a
different spot in the mirrored wall to
move with Bruce to a different location
as hubs explained that complicated the
image a lot because we were shooting
into a mirror and the mirror bounced all
around you actually got nauseous in the
room Bruce banged himself into the
mirrors a whole bunch
for a movie that was so financially
successful and had such a lasting Legacy
you might be struck by how few household
names star in it in fact the only actor
from the movie who would go on to
achieve stardom was an unnamed extra a
young martial artist named Jackie Chan
Chan would continue making movies
gaining attention for drunken master in
1978 and then the police Story series it
should be noted that both were produced
by Golden Harvest a company owned by
Raymond Chao they got a huge Boost from
Bruce Lee films most western audiences
first discovered him in rush hour and
he's been in seemingly countless
Hollywood action films since
since Enter the Dragon was a martial
arts film shot in Hong Kong with a
mostly Chinese cast there was bound to
be some peacocking the extras had some
training and supposedly one of them
actually challenged Lee to a real fight
many people wanted to test Lee's
fighting skills as his standard within
the martial arts Community according to
a vintage interview with cast member
bolo Young Lee was too fast for his
Challenger and one although the extra
did land a few blows in the end whether
participating in a choreographed or
actual fight it seems Lee couldn't be
defeated by fist footer weapon
the budget for Enter the Dragon was 850
000 which might seem low but at the time
there had been no big Hollywood martial
arts movies producer Fred Weintraub
explained in a q a for the film's 40th
anniversary release that it was tough to
get the funding saying I had to go to
foreign investment the foreign guy told
me well I can get you two or three
hundred thousand out of the Far East and
I said that's all you have offended my
family
and you have offended The Shaolin Temple
apparently the Chinese market was not
interested in an American Film starring
an actor from Hong Kong after that
Weintraub approached Warner Brothers
co-owner Ted Ashley to ask for another
three hundred thousand dollars which
Ashley agreed to provide with a
condition that he did not spend a dime
more the hustle paid off in Spades
however Enter the Dragon landed at
number 13 on the list of top grossing
films of 1973 and was Warner Brothers
third highest grossing film of the Year
Enter the Dragon not only showed that
martial arts movies could play in
America it showed that they could
dominate with the movie ultimately
earning more than 21 million dollars in
the US alone
according to an interview with Fred
Weintraub by Black Belt Magazine the
nightclub owner turned producer at
Warner Brothers had learned about Lee
through his Golden Harvest films and
wanted to make a Hollywood picture with
him when Warner Brothers finally
produced Enter the Dragon it was Lee's
first great exposure on American soil
aside from his role as Cato in the
short-lived 1966 TV series The Green
Hornet after the success of Lee's Hong
Kong movies he was finally able to make
a Hollywood movie and make it on his
terms unfortunately during what should
have been Lee's great moment to flurry
in the premiere of his first Hollywood
film Lee wasn't present the movie
premiered on August 19 1973 but Lee had
already passed away on July 20th of the
same year the cause of death was a
cerebral edema or swelling of the brain
he died while filming his next movie
game of death which might have cemented
him as Hollywood's next great leading
man
you would be hard-pressed to find a
Hollywood film featuring martial arts
before Enter the Dragon much less
focusing on it a great example of how
things changed is found in the Zeitgeist
following James Bond movies in
Goldfinger the only martial artist is a
powerfully built man of unnamed Asian
descent whose skills consist of being
very strong and throwing a steel-lined
hat in 1967s you only lived twice Bond
goes to a ninja school who students are
used as a mercenary Army by the man with
a golden gun which came out in 1974. Han
puts on a ghee and does karate himself
when people talk about classic Kung Fu
movies they're often referring to the
movies produced by The Shaw Brothers in
Hong Kong which at the time were mostly
only hits in China after Enter the
Dragon American action movies began to
feature choreographed martial arts
fights martial arts swept the UK and
North America in the early 1970s and
never left
foreign
[Music]